[Música]
se você lembra da última vez que você
sente uma profunda sensação de bem-estar
de dever cumprido
você se lembra da última vez que você
sentiu útil
eu me sinto assim praticamente todos os
dias
muita gente acha que eu sou formada em
jornalismo mas na verdade eu me formei
publicidade como eu amo escrever
acabei me especializando como redatora e
aí fui escrevendo todo tipo de anúncio
até aquele famoso aniversário é nosso
mas quem ganha o presente é você
fiz várias vezes vida que segue na
carreira iniciando a gente não questiona
muita coisa
eu me mudei para o rio me casei tive
dois filhos incríveis e conquistei um
emprego na tv globo
eu comecei como pesquisador de texto mas
aos poucos eu fui ali colocando meu
espaço e acabei me tornando o roteirista
mas na televisão quando você quer se
aprende de tudo eu aprendi muito sobre
produção direção e edição eu vi várias
celebridades conhecia alguns artistas
mas sabe que fez meu olho brilhar nessa
experiência toda um quadro que a gente
fazia no tv xuxa onde a gente realizava
sonhos os telespectadores mandavam
cartas contando quais eram seus sonhos
ea gente selecionar as melhores para
realizar
mas não bastava só selecionar carta eu
tinha que ir lá conhecer a pessoa como
ela vivia como era família rotina e
principalmente de que forma que a
realização daquele sonho e impactar a
vida dela e com isso acabei viajando
muito
fui conhecendo um brasil que eu não
sabia que existia me conhecendo pessoas
que jamais encontraria em outra ocasião
e sem perceber
eu fui sair da bolha eu fui descobrindo
novos mundos prevendo novas formas de se
ver e principalmente de sonhar é uma
reunião de pauta com a xuxa o conhecer e
ivete sangalo
não me emocionou tanto como no dia que
eu dei pra carla a festa de casamento do
jeitinho que ela sonhava poder fazer
algo por alguém me encantou me senti
útil me fez muito bem e quando a gente
faz uma coisa que a gente gosta que a
gente sente propósito a gente quer cada
vez mais né
só que o tv xuxa acabou e os outros
programas para onde foi realocada não
fizeram o menor sentido pra mim ali
terminava o meu ciclo na tv globo e no
rio de janeiro
mas agora eu voltei para belo horizonte
completamente sem saber o que é que eu
ia fazer da minha vida
uma coisa eu tinha certeza o aniversário
é nosso mas quem ganha o presente é você
não dava mais pra fazer eu queria alguma
coisa que me fizesse sentido que me
fizesse me senti útil de novo mas o que
é isso
um dia estava fuçando na internet
navegando por aí e vi um anúncio de uma
empresa que estava convocando uma turma
para fazer trabalho voluntário no sertão
do piauí
eu sou uma pessoa que eu acredito sempre
ensinar isso tudo eu acho que é um sinal
pra mim e eu bati o olho aquele anúncio
falei esse negócio é para mim
instintivamente resolvida com uma câmera
que eu tinha em casa nada profissional
mas quem sabe eu nem consegui colocar em
prática de novo tudo que eu tinha
aprendido naqueles anos todos de
televisão e assim o embarque para cauã
uma cidadezinha com 8 mil habitantes e
foi com o objetivo de registrar são de
13 voluntários que largaram suas vidas e
seus afazeres para reformar uma fábrica
de brinquedos de madeira
quem te vê dessa fábrica foi um cara do
espírito santo júnior que se mudou pra
cá o am para entender como aquelas
pessoas viviam e de que forma que ele
poderia ajudar já que 70% da população
não têm ensino médio e vivem basicamente
de agricultura
detalhe da chave uma vez por ano
e assim surgiu o time dos sonhos uma
fábrica de brinquedos de madeira que tem
dado uma nova perspectiva
aquelas pessoas e transformado a
realidade daquela comunidade
eu nunca me imaginei envolvida numa ação
como essa eu vou ser muito sincera eu
nunca tinha ouvido falar em
empreendedorismo social
eu não sabia que no sertão as pessoas
pudessem ser tão felizes e que o sonho
de uma pessoa pudesse ser apenas chuva e
como eu não sabia de nada disso muita
gente também poderia não saber eu vou
ter de acabar a mexida era aquilo que eu
queria fazer mas eu não sabia como
como chegar até outros lugares como
conheceu mais pessoas assim
será que isso daria para transformar em
trabalho passou um furacão na minha
cabeça
aliás não só na minha cabeça em outubro
de 2016
o furacão méxico passou contudo pelo
caribe e o país mais devastado foi o
haiti
eu via na televisão aquelas pessoas
implorando por ajuda e eu queria muito
poder ajudar
mesmo de longe eu não sabia como é isso
que aquela empresa que me levou para
cauã lançou uma viagem pra noite era não
era um outro sinal pra mim eu
interpretei que era mas e aí agora não
dava pra vão pra bancar essa viagem
sozinha eu lembrei de uma lição que
aprendi com a xuxa não poder trabalhar
com ela mas aos oito anos de idade
quando ela diz que tudo que eu quiser
o cara lá de cima vai me dar o cara me
deu me deu muita coragem e muita cara de
pau porque resolvi fazer um canal onde
um financiamento coletivo
eu bati na porta de todo mundo todo
mundo que eu conhecia falava oi prazer
meu nome é silvio eu estou a fim de
participar pode me ajudar eu me
decepcionei demais
me surpreendi demais mas o que importa é
que eu consegui a grana pra mim e eu não
fui sozinho não foi eu a minha câmera
nada profissional e dessa vez eu comprei
uma gol pronto porque foi assim aos
poucos eu fui montando minha equipe
e lá fomos nós só que o haiti não era
nada do que eu esperava
era muito melhor enquanto eu vi aquele
caos generalizado na televisão eu
encontrei as pessoas mais resilientes e
fortes que eu já vi na minha vida
pessoas dispostas a refazerem não só as
suas vidas como de outras pessoas também
eu vi a bandeira de tudo quanto é país
eu vi gente de tudo quanto é lugar
doação de tudo quanto é tipo eu vi a cor
de mar mais linda do mundo e as crianças
as crianças mais encantadoras que eu já
encontrei o haiti me fez me apaixonar
não só pelo haitiano mas pelo trabalho
voluntário pela vontade de produzir
conteúdos de cunho social pela vontade
de querer sair da bolha e mostrar para
as pessoas o mundo que tem lá fora
aliás aqui fora e ninguém percebe
felizmente foi assistindo à maior crise
humanitária do século evento pessoas
sendo rotulados apenas como refugiados é
que eu também não me conformei e foi
parar num campo de refugiados sírios no
líbano enquanto sites jornais falavam em
número de sobreviventes de vítimas ou de
pessoas dentro de um bote
eu queria saber nome e sobrenome como
eles viviam para onde estavam indo que
eles vão fazer e principalmente como eu
poderia ajudar
essa talvez seja a pergunta mais difícil
e sem querer acabou sendo mais fácil de
responder porque por incrível que pareça
eu consegui ajudar uma família através
de uma simples xícara de chá foi
entrando na tenda da família assad e
perguntando pra ele sobre a trajetória
até aquele campo que eu escutei o
seguinte comentário da mãe dessa família
hoje é um dos dias mais felizes da minha
vida desde que eu pisei nesse campo
porque enquanto jornalistas do mundo
todo passam aqui a cena de longe tirou
dezenas de fotos minhas e sequer
pergunta o meu nome
você hoje pediu para entrar na minha
casa você sentou no chão com um amigo
bebeu do meu chá e quis me escutar
simples né simples estar disponível para
alguém simples escutar alguém as tribos
típico konibu no peru elas estão
desaparecendo do mapa
justamente por não estarem sendo ouvidas
ele sequer recebem o mínimo de
infraestrutura o atendimento médico mas
sabe por que eu viajei 20 horas de barco
até lá foi pra ver um bando de jovens a
campari sob um sol de 40 graus comerem
peixe e mandioca no café da manhã no
almoço e se sobrar no jantar
eu fui ver médicos e dentistas fazerem
atendimento de sete da manhã às sete da
noite sem parar e chorarem no final do
dia porque não tinha conseguido atender
todo mundo
na amazônia foi acompanhando um grupo de
gaúchos que descobriram que na vila
monteiro onde moram 80 pessoas
a escola não estava mais funcionando por
falta de professor
eles tiveram a idéia de construir uma
biblioteca para estimular os jovens a
leitura e quem sabe eles ensinarão os
mais novos há como ler e escrever
só que eles não me contaram que eu ia
ter que entrar na floresta carregar
ripas de madeira bater prego preparar
cimento na beira do rio buscarei a
pintar eu achava que tem levado 250
livros na minha mala já era o suficiente
mas não além de ler os livros para as
crianças
eu precisava contar essa história para
as pessoas é isso
com uma câmera na mão eu queria contar
histórias do bem
histórias que enchessem as pessoas de
esperança
eu precisava contar para as pessoas a
onda de puro amor e compaixão que se
formou em brumadinho
eu conheci um cara que saiu da cidade
dele viajou dois dias para entregar 30
cestas básicas para quem ele nunca viu
na vida
dormiu no próprio carro e voltou no dia
seguinte cedo porque ele não podia
perder um dia de trabalho
olha eu conheci uma mulher que escolheu
passar o dia do aniversário dela junto
às aos familiares das vítimas e disse
que aquele foi o melhor aniversário da
vida dela
isso é não é de encher o peito de
esperança mas pra mim esperança faz
sentido quando ela pode ser
compartilhada
eu tenho certeza que não sou só eu que
acredito que esse mundo tá cheio de
gente do bem e se alguém pensa o
contrário eu tenho todos os motivos do
mundo para fazer essa pessoa mudar de
idéia
foi por isso que eu transformei o
instagram o facebook linkedin e youtube
e qualquer outra rede social que
apareceu na minha frente em fonte de
conteúdos do bem
fui na vontade de conhecer mais e mais
pessoas assim que eu propus para uma
rádio aqui de belo horizonte um quadro
quinzenal onde eu apresento pessoas que
estão fazendo a diferença na nossa
cidade
pessoas que tiram água de pedra que
fazem o impossível acontecer e que
percebem que as nossas diferenças
começam aqui ó na nossa capacidade de
nos arrepiamos ou não
quando ouvimos histórias do bem
[Música]
o mundo tá esquisito né tem muita
notícia ruim todos os dias e é
justamente por essa quantidade tão
grande de notícias que a gente não pode
só ficar lamentando essas informações
que chegam que você tem feito com as
notícias que consome
em tempos de hard news fast news ou fake
news
eu optei por produzir google news ou
simplesmente histórias do bem
mas ninguém precisa sair com uma câmera
na mão e trabalhar com a xuxa ou sprite
não pra ajudar
não tem fórmula mágica vale tudo não
existe pequena ou grande ação existe
querer fazer o bem a diferença e quando
a gente muda a vida de alguém
quando a gente ajuda alguém nós nos
transformamos e percebemos que ninguém é
melhor do que todos nós juntos histórias
pra contar o que não falta mas sabe que
é o melhor dá pra todo mundo seu
protagonista e o responsável por um
final feliz
muito obrigado
[Música]